[Music]
[Applause]
all the world's a stage and all the men
and women merely players rings a bell -
with William Shakespeare about 400 years
back yeah that's him just so if you
haven't gone across the speech let me
give you a little synopsis it talks
about the various stages that we go
through in our lives if we develop
starting from an infant to a toddler
school boy a lover a soldier and so on
till the end stage of senility now if
you're wondering as to why am I talking
about Shakespeare instead of beginning
to narrate one of my grandmother's tales
and my experiences yours right this very
first line your got me thinking why
Shakespeare didn't tell us what kind of
players we are supposed to be see as
children we've constantly heard these
moral stories from our grandparents and
parents is through the certain ways in
which we should behave how we should act
towards others how good conquers evil
and many more lessons right then when we
go to school our ideologies about the
world and these moral stories slowly
starts changing let me show you how I'm
pretty sure a fair amount of us have
tried our hands at the methods of sleep
but haven't we always been told honesty
is the best policy no you don't have to
admit it here but just think for
yourself how far is it really
advantageous to you today you cheat
tomorrow you pass the day after tomorrow
you're acknowledged but days after
tomorrow you're not able to apply and
then you fail which gives disheartening
and start complaining but you know all
this wouldn't have happened if only we
had been honest with ourselves this is
exactly where we start letting go of
those little lessons we were told in
childhood and then finally when we enter
the face of the soldier
somehow whatever we learned in our
childhood is forgotten in our endeavor
to conquer the world isn't it today we
live in a world that's a home to all
kinds of people while some are honest
and play they are gamers lives with
integrity honesty love and affection
towards God's lovely creations there are
others who dealt our lives and hatred
anger jealousy revenge and calculated
assumptions
well now you would say that emotions are
subjective which is true because all of
us go through these various emotions in
these different stages in our lives and
all our lives end up being caught out in
different ways but what about the
choices we make as a person what about
the way we choose to respond to
unforeseen circumstances that's up to us
do we still Gary those childhood fables
in the back of our mind while making
these decisions or are they lost in our
transition from the infancy to
adolescence to the Justice when I was a
kid I used to believe in the tooth fairy
I used to feel that if I loved everyone
and helped everyone she would come and
grant me my wishes of course back then
my wishes were only chocolate ice cream
and rainbow cake but now that I've grown
up I've started realizing that people
don't actually believe in the ideas they
were once brought up with so what
happened to all those little life
lessons that we were once told does it
matter if we behave in a certain way
does it make a difference if we do the
right thing or not we all start out with
these ideas and dreams but then as we go
through life we lose some of those
values can't we try harder or do more to
hold on to the ideas we've once had as
children now you might be thinking what
is the need to hold onto these bedtime
stories after all they were just meant
to put us to sleep help us get through
school with good grades and discipline
us as children but what we often
overlook is to impact these long learnt
life's lessons
on our everyday lives and on those
around us and you'll be surprised to
know how closely our actions and their
consequences are related okay let me ask
you something have you heard about the
notion of karma and the karmic cycle
remember Shakespeare's Macbeth Macbeth
was easily tempted into murder to
fulfill his ambitions to the throne but
he was never comfortable in his role as
a criminal and ultimately he was unable
to bear the psychological consequences
of his actions whereas on the other hand
let's have a look at me
so my friends keep telling me you don't
have to be this curry to shoes nice
person all the time and then one amazing
day when I received the invitation to
speak at Q I was pretty much in a state
of shock and my best friend said just
wanting to me that made me believe this
is actually happening see all the good
things that you do to everyone are
coming back to you and Here I am
standing right before you feeling so
special there you go this is exactly
what the philosophy of karma states what
goes around comes around somewhat like a
domino effect so see do good things then
good things will come back to us and the
same goes for the bad I mean come on
people when stuff doesn't work out for
us the way we wanted to we start
complaining but with I suggest is that
why don't we realize that we are the
cause and the target of our own
circumstances and actions how can we
blame others for our situation consider
the scenario you are dining in a
restaurant you ordered four dishes and
the waiter brought all four but by
mistake billed you only for three what
would you do there you see here is my
little secret every time you find
yourself in such a dilemma try going
back to those childhood favors we were
once told and ask ourselves what would
you have done then
you've heard of the saying as you sow so
shall you reap so if you sow the seeds
with love that's the kind of fruit we
land joy
whereas if intentionally or
unintentionally be done to act selfishly
that's what we will get back thank you
and remember the eyes of truth are
always watching you
[Applause]